Democrats have been sworn into the new
Congress Democratic congresswoman Nancy
Pelosi is the new Speaker of the House
third in line for the presidency of
course behind Donald Trump and Mike
Pence Democrats now in control of the
house and within just hours of being
sworn in
Democrats successfully passed a bill to
end the Trump government shutdown now
unfortunately the bill is dead in the
water in the Senate and with Donald
Trump because number one it does not
contain funding for Donald Trump's
border wall which Mexico was going to be
paying for and number two because both
Trump and Mitch McConnell have said they
can't reopen government on the basis of
a democratic bill because they would
look bad exposing that they are just
playing the worst politics that
Washington is a purveyor of and when you
look at the package that was passed by
the house mostly along party lines 239
to 192
this bill would end the shutdown by
temporarily funding the Department of
Homeland Security at its current levels
for a little over a month and it would
allow discussions to continue about a
longer term plan for what's going to be
done it would not as I mentioned fund
the border wall at all good for
Democrats for not budging on that
whatsoever
then in addition to this bill Democrats
also put together another measure to get
the Department of Agriculture the
Department of the Interior and a bunch
of other departments reopened and funded
through September 30th two-thirds of
2019 they approved that one 241 to 190
by a slightly bigger margin than they
approved the homeland security bill what
is fascinating about this and really
maybe disgusting and vile is a better
word is that it exposes the politics
being played because the builds fund
Homeland Security that Democrats
approved yesterday in the house is
almost identical to the one that the
republican-controlled Senate adopted
with a voice vote last month except the
next day they rejected it and forced the
shutdown that we're now dealing with the
same plan is now approved in the house
but Republicans in the Senate are
even going to consider it based on what
we know right now Mitch McConnell is
actually trying to do something clever
he's been trying to sort of get out of
the way let Trump and Democrats talk
about the wall funding and getting this
back open whenever it is they decide to
do it and in a sense it worked to push
some blame to Democrats for this
shutdown but it's starting to fail now
because Republicans in the Senate are
starting to ramp up their 20/20
campaigns remember that every two years
a third of the Senate is up for
re-election in 2020 it's many
Republicans now a lot of them are in red
states that means that there are lots of
safe seats for Republicans but in total
Republicans have many seats to defend in
2020 and a shutdown that goes on longer
and longer is not going to be good for
some of those Republican senators who
are in either swing states or in states
that Hillary won in 2016 you can see the
calculations being made here and the
calculations are not about what actually
secures the border or what is best for
immigration the calculations that these
swing state Republicans are making are
political calculations case in point
Cory Gardner Republican Senator in
Colorado he has this uphill battle in
2020 one of the most at-risk Republican
seats and lo and behold he now is saying
we should actually reopen government
without border wall funding he's quoted
in The New York Times as saying I think
we should pass a continuing resolution
to get the government back open Susan
Collins we've talked about her a role in
the fiasco of the Brett Kavanaugh
Supreme Court confirmation Republican
from Maine she is a target in 2020
because of her role in the Cavanaugh
fiasco she now is saying oh you know
what it would actually be fine to
separate funding for the Department of
Homeland Security from funding for the
border wall and just getting government
reopened so when the rubber meets the
road Pat it's just political
considerations they all know what the
calculation is they are making it for
2020 not for border security yeah
generally speaking there's no more
incentive for politicians to get along
and compromise anymore but there are
exceptions to that rule
like you have to eventually get the
government back open and there are those
Republicans in purple states who are
gonna have to find some solution to they
can hold so they can hold on to their
seats so we're gonna have to find some
way out of this I think it's going to be
maybe a couple billion dollars put
towards border security not necessarily
a wall but that could be the place where
Democrats meet Republicans in the middle
and that could be the solution to
getting the government back open that
may be but I do want to mention as far
as Gardner and Collins are concerned
they may just be playing coy here with
their purple state Republican
constituents so until they actually vote
on something even if they say they
support reopening government even that
could in and of itself just be posturing
but the important message here is none
of them actually care about the issue at
hand
Trump's border wall one way or the other
if the political ramifications are good
for them is actually not that important
whether it gets built or not today's
sponsor is Skillshare and I'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skill shares
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about
or discover something brand-new that you
didn't even know that you would love and
join skill shares other 7 million users
by clicking the link underneath this
video
[Music]